gas prices continue to increase across
the country here in las vegas our
average is up 10 cents from yesterday at
477 a gallon the national average 425
right now even diesel in las vegas broke
that five dollar barrier as those gas
prices continue to soar not just drivers
but station owners are concerned that's
right well mary jane belliesa is live
this afternoon at a gas station on
decatur and desert inn and mary jane i
understand gas store owners say their
customers aren't the only ones feeling
the pain at the pump
that's absolutely right christian gas
store owners tell me that while they try
to keep gas costs as low as they can
they don't control the prices now it all
comes down to deliveries brand and state
regulations
just over the weekend alone we've gone
up 80 cents in gas sebastian vellis is
the general manager at conoco at all las
vegas locations he says he doesn't see
gas prices going down anytime soon with
everything going on in the world the war
going on right now with ukraine and
russia supply is
is limited right now and demands very
high so that's why you guys see the
prices going up so much right now and
gas isn't the only item velus is worried
about merchandise it can get expired
you know
our sales go down as the gas prices go
up our store sales go down because not a
lot of people are looking to spend money
inside the store now people are worried
about if they have enough money to get
gas for the week vellis isn't alone fred
smith is the owner of fabulous freddies
in las vegas and utah smith says the
bank fees alone are squeezing his wallet
dry credit card fees are probably what's
going to really make an impact on gas
stations just because we we pay for
those no matter what and you know gas
doubles and solar fees for now smith
says there isn't any delays for gas
deliveries and will continue to offer
the best customer service they can no
but it really isn't
up to us and we get our costs from
shell in las vegas and they tell us
where we need to be and
then we've got to figure out we take as
long as we possibly can to
raise them
but you'll see that once somebody
paying on the deliveries once somebody
gets their gas delivery that's when all
stores start raising their prices
both gas stations i spoke to say they're
trying to offer incentives for customers
during this time at conoco they try to
keep the lowest gas price on their
street compared to other gas stations
and at fabulous freddy's they do offer
to pump your gas for you or if you
purchase a car wash they'll be able to
knock a few cents off a gallon when you
do go pumped your gas reporting here on
decatur and desert in mary jane vallesa
live local now